Good Morning John.
I want to start this off by saying that I
am not a doctor, I'm not a counselor, I haven't
experienced sexual abuse, I'm just a person
with some thoughts that hopefully could be
helpful.
To someone.
Sex is complicated, in like, every way imaginable.
This is not aided by the fact that we have
a general societal taboo against discussing
it.
So when we do talk about it, it's often shrouded
in metaphors and innuendo and bombasticity.
That means a lot of the sexual norms of our
culture are mysterious, and we don't actually
talk about them; we just sort of infer them.
I think that's dumb.
And that's part of why I helped Nick and Lindsey
start sexplanations.
I think that our culture has kind of a messed
up relationship with sex.
We somehow have made these relationships,
uh, into, like, predator/prey relationships.
Like, one person is the, you know, the cruise
missile of desire, and the other one is the
sweet, chaste little kitten.
And the cruise missile has to get the kitten
and the kitten runs away.
I don't know why it's a cruise missile and
a kitten.
I do know, though, that this is a dumb system.
I think that a lot of the joy and wonder and
excitement of a romantic relationship comes
from those moments of excitedly discovering
that both parties are into this.
We're in- we're both into this!
That's a great feeling!
The attack missile/kitten relationship does
not encourage that.
I wanna be clear, I'm explaining culture but
I'm not excusing the behavior.
When we're set up to assume that the kitten
is gonna run whether the kitten wants the
cruise missile or not, that enables abuse.
In my opinion this is, I'm sure not all of
the reason, but one of of the big reasons
why sexual abuse is so common in our culture.
Okay, I said sexual abuse, but what- what
is sexual abuse?
Legally, the definition has to be very specific,
so that it can stand up in court.
So it's different state to state, country
to country.
But for the purposes of having a general definition,
let's just say that sexual abuse is when one
party is being coerced into doing something
sexual that they do not want to do.
That can be because the victim is incapacitated,
or because the abuser is an authority figure,
or because the victim is placed in a dangerous
situation where they feel like they don't
have the option of saying no or getting out
of the situation.
The gender of the parties is irrelevant, it
can be sex, it can be kissing.
If one person doesn't want to be doing what
they are doing and they are being coerced
or pressured into doing it, then that is abuse.
And it is ubiquitous.
And it needs to not be, because it holds us
back as a culture.
We have to rid ourselves of that outdated
and rotten conception that sexual relationships
are like predator/prey things.
Let's zoom in for this.
Romantic relationships can be wonderful, but
you have to have that magical thing, consent.
And not saying no is not the same as saying
yes.
We need to communicate, we need to be sensitive,
we need to talk about what we do and don't
want to do, and we have to respect and NOT
pressure people when they don't want to do
something.
This video is part of a long conversation
that is going to continue to be had for a
long time.
But John and I have some ideas about how to
keep it moving.
First, we've already started working with
a group of nerdfighters, including some survivors
of sexual abuse, who will be working as a
task force against abuse and assault.
Second, we want to produce and fund a series
of videos that discusses abuse and consent
and sexual relationships, especially in light
of the new digital world, like where does
Skype fit into it all, right?
And third, we're looking to partner with some
existing sexual assault organizations to bring
their work and their resources into our community,
and hopefully into other online communities
as well.
John, I know we're not gonna fix the whole
world but I'm pleased to be in a position
where we can at least start to help enable
some positive change.
I'll see you on Tuesday.
If you're in an abusive relationship or you
think you might be and you're just not sure,
there are links in the description to help
you figure out where you're at, and to people
who you can call or go to for help.
Sometimes just figuring out the abusive nature
of a relationship can be a huge challenge,
and once you're in there, it can seem like
it is impossible to escape, but it is not.